There are a couple possibilities here. We're working with a partially
filled array. So, do we want to use an enhanced for loop or
a regular for loop? If we use the enhanced for loop, it'll
add up every single item, even the ones in the part of
the array that we've said is empty. We know that the
current size is four but the enhanced for loop. Just notice how
much space there is in the whole array. In this case, the
enhanced for loop will work, but only because the array was initialized
full of zeros. So, when we take the sum and we add
all of these zeros, it won't actually give us the wrong answer.
But if I were dealing with an array that might have extra
junk left over in the empty space, I would probably want to use a
regular for loop. And only go up to the currentsize of four.
I'll show you both of those. Either way, I'll need my sum that
starts at 0, and I'll return that sum at the end. If
I used the enhanced for loop, I just increment the sum by score,
each time, and that should work. But if I'm nervous that there
might be other junk left over, in the end of my array,
then I would declare a loop counter variable. And stop before it
gets up to current size, and look at each item one at
a time. And here I would have to get item out of
scores, because I'm not using an enhanced for loop anymore, and I
should actually give my, [LAUGH], loop counter variable an initial value. Now
we can see this in action, if I run the demo and
enter my scores, I get their total.